Hi, I'm Chet Haas, an engineer
on the Android Team at Google.
So I saw a talk recently at
Google I/O where they were
showing some example animation
code, which I always like.
And I saw something curious
there, which was someone said,
well, we need to animate a
couple of properties at the
same time on the same
target object.
And we can't do that directly
with Object Animator.
So we're going to use the Value
Animator Object and do
it more manually.
And I thought, hm, that's
not actually correct.
So I realized at that point--
I thought this was obvious,
how to do this.
And I realized maybe it would
be good if I actually
explained how to do
this in general.
There's a class called Property
Values Holder that
you might want to know about if
you need to do this on your
own targets and properties.
So I have a demo to show you
here with four simple buttons
on it, all of which want
to be animated.
And you'll notice
that all of them
animate remarkably similarly.
In fact, it's effectively the
same animation happening on
all of them.
But the code for doing
it is very different.
So for the first button,
we use a
Value Animator animation.
And the example that I saw in
this particular talk said, OK,
we're going to use
Value Animator.
And this will return a value
between 0 and 1.
And then we take this value,
and we figure out what the
target value should be on the
target object that we're
trying to animate.
So I do that here.
So the approach to doing this
with the Value Animator is you
create your Value Animator
between start and end values.
Here, it doesn't actually matter
what those values are,
because we're going
to be using the
animated fraction anyway.
And then we add an Update
Listener so that we get a call
back on every single
animation frame.
And then during that frame, we
get the animated fraction.
This gives us a value between
0 and 1 to tell us where, in
the course of this animation,
the animation is.
And then we can take that
value and use it to
interpolate the value of
our end targets and end
properties.
So here we simply set the
translation x and the
translation y values directly
on the object with a simple
linear interpolation.
And then we start
the animation.
Very straightforward.
But there are easier ways to do
this with a lot less code.
The second one is probably the
easiest way to do this.
An important point to note here
is I would always use
View Property Animator in this
particular situation.
I'm animating properties on
a view, translation x and
translation y.
And this is exactly why View
Property Animator was created.
The code is very simple
and streamlined.
You can do things in parallel
in the same animation.
And it's very efficient at
animating multiple things,
because it has intrinsic
knowledge about views that
make its invalidation and
rendering and update system
very efficient internally.
So it's the right
thing to use.
But sometimes you're animating
things that aren't simply
properties on a view, in which
case you couldn't use View
Property Animator.
And you'll need to use one of
the techniques that I show a
little bit later.
So if you can use View Property
Animator, here's how
it would work.
You would call Animate
on the View.
That returns a View Property
Animator object.
And then it would
say translation
x to the end value.
Translation y to
the end value.
And you're done.
Don't need to call start.
Don't need to do these in
separate statements.
You're basically just building
up the animation.
And when you're done building
it, it automatically starts in
the next frame.
And you're good to go.
Straightforward.
Easy to use.
Use View Property Animator.
But if you can't--
maybe you're looking at using
Object Animators instead.
So this is what the example
that I saw was trying to
avoid, was creating multiple
Object Animators, even though
you're only animating
one object.
We all know that creating more
and more objects, especially
during animations, may
be a bad thing.
So maybe you want
to avoid this.
But it's fairly straightforward.
This is maybe the trivial
approach to solving this
problem with an Object Animator,
which is I want one
Object Animator that animates
the values for translation x.
I want another Object Animator
that animates the values for
translation y.
And I want you to start
both of them.
Pretty simple.
If you need to choreograph it
a little more carefully, you
can use an Animator Set.
Add these things into play
sequentially or play together
or play with other animators.
All very straightforward.
Not a big deal.
But you are creating a couple
of Object Animators that are
sort of running without
knowledge of each other.
And maybe that's just not as
efficient at what you really
wanted to do.
What you really wanted to
do was the following.
You want to use property
values holders.
This is actually what Object
Animator uses internally.
But you can access it
on the outside too.
In this case, we're animating
the same object, but we're
animating multiple
properties on the
same object in parallel.
So what we're going to do is
set up a property's value
holder to animate our
translation x
property to the end value.
Another property values holder
to animate the translation y
property on the same object.
And then we're going to set
up the Object Animator.
And this is what associates the
property values holders
with the actual target
object of our view.
So now that we've set up the
property values holder, we
come down here, and we create
a single Object Animator.
And we say, OK, on our target
view I want you to use this
property value holder for
translation x, the other
property values holder for
translation y, and I want you
to start it.
And bang.
You're done.
So animating multiple properties
in parallel on the
same target object, View
Property Animator
if you can use it.
Property Values Holder
if you can't.
Thanks.